and I finally get to see the movie that
everyone's raving about
that's my Western voice I like it now
Rango is the story of a chameleon voiced
by Johnny Depp and notice the
similarities to Johnny Depp's picture on
the poster of Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas just saying who's ultimately a
really wimpy method actor who comes
across a town called dirt which is a
really generous name considering the
town looks like [ __ ] and after that
Western adventure ensues and this town
needs a sheriff and dubs Rango it after
that corruption good guys bad guys
Johnny Depp sheriff's and Western
adventure ensues now I will say this
this is one of those movies I was sure
it was over high by the time I saw it
it's been out for like two weeks and it
was actually really good Great Western
if you like westerns you will like Rango
fact you might just love it the
characters in this movie were textbook
K's Western characters I am pretty sure
I've seen all these people in Clint
Eastwood movies and the bar scene in
Back to the Future 3 there's this one
dude I forgot his name I just called him
big head he's this little dude with the
big spiky head he was the best I liked
him now the premises this town is out of
water it's in a huge drought and Johnny
Depp gives him hope so they're like oh
yeah we love you man now please help us
and so he's like ok but he's not he's
not that badass they think he is it's
all just [ __ ] he's just an actor but
I like movies where average people are
given the opportunity to be great
how else are we supposed to relate to
him at the beginning of this movie
looked like it was playing on the whole
weird Johnny Depp thing you know the
whole Pirates of the Caribbean Johnny
Depp weirdness that we see him in in
everything nowadays but it comes down
after the first scene and after that
it's cool now the CGI in this movie was
absolutely badass it looks crazy real to
a creepy degree and it's not made for
kids older kids and adults there are
just jokes in the movie that kids won't
get but adults will love them and there
is a cameo that's probably the most
badass thing that you could possibly do
in a movie like this or most movies but
westerns Pacific and the cinematography
was badass so it has cool characters
funny moments great action great
cinematography and it's a Western what's
not to like
Rango is proof that Gore Verbinski can
make a great movie if he's not still
writing the script after he's already
started filming you know what I'm
talking about it took a little while to
get going but once it does it's a badass
movie and it's not in 3d I thought it
would be so there's like five bucks
you'll save right there so for Rango I
would say I would buy it even
here it is imagine a Western where an
average guy becomes a sheriff and has to
take on corruption and save a town and
the movies told with characters that are
lizards and rodents
that's Rango but if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more but definitely
watch Rango great movie of 2011 for sure